before i ask you about a
one but several really exciting studies
let me ask sort of a personal question
for me so
if i wanted to get psychedelics
from the maps public benefit
corporation and uh explore my own mind
um how do i get to do that uh and when
you won't be able to you'll never be
able this is very unfortunate
because the the reason is because the
benefit corp is
designed as a pharmaceutical company so
we can only
work on clinical indication so let's say
you you come to me and you just say oh
i'm really depressed
can i get mdma to overcome my depression
or overcome my ptsd you know we'll have
to do research in those indications
and by when you say me you mean like a
doctor so this would be prescribed in
theory by doctors well this would go
through a doctor
yes and a prescription okay let me uh
let me ask another question
to further answer so so that's where the
drug policy arm comes in
the drug policy reform so you should be
able to get
access to psychedelics for your own
personal growth yes
but that's not medicine so that's why we
need
to medicalize to have things covered by
insurance
to change people's attitudes the public
attitudes and then
we get this subsequent drug policy
reform
and and we're talking about it in terms
of licensed legalization so my view is
you should get a license to
do psychedelics you get a little
education stuff and then then you should
be able to buy it and do it on your own
so let me rephrase the question
more specifically so when can i if i
happen to have
um ailments of some kind where the
doctor decides that psychedelics could
help
when would you be a loose estimate for
you
of when a doctor would be able to
prescribe to me something from
uh maps public benefit co and then when
for my personal growth and creativity
would i be able to get something so like
just looking out this isn't like
guaranteed but like your vision your
hope
yeah um for yeah for for academics in
society
well the end of 2023 so two and a half
years from now
we anticipate fda approval for the
prescription use of mdma for ptsd
because the fda does not
regulate the practice of medicine there
is what's called off-label prescription
what that means the label is what it's
approved for so the label says this is
approved for ptsd
and but let's say you come in anything
else social anxiety or whatever
you can go to the doctor they can give
it to you it might not be covered by
insurance they have to be a little bit
careful about malpractice if they're
but i think the end of 2023 is when
you will be able to do that now there's
actually another program
very limited called expanded access
which is compassionate use
which means that and we have approval
for 50 people
for compassionate use right now we think
that'll grow
so that's going to open up in about two
months and so those are
people with ptsd they have to be
treatment resistant nothing has worked
for them and they can
access mdma while we're doing the phase
three studies wow
and but they have to pay for it
themselves we're not the sponsor has to
pay for all the research but
expanded access because there's no
control group
everybody gets the mdma people can pay
for it themselves and we think that'll
start in a couple months
but it's very limited it's limited to
certain cities there's also a program
called right to try
which is um passed through congress it's
it's
it's similar this idea of compassionate
use but it cuts the
fda out of it and patients can negotiate
directly with
pharma companies to get access to their
drugs
that's starting to happen i think in
canada now they're letting
people have compassionate access to
psilocybin
for life-threatening illness because
there has been studies with psilocybin
for cancer patients and others with
life-threatening illness
as far as your question about when will
you be able to access this
for personal growth outside of medicine
i'll take that to mean you know fully
legally where you can just go buy pure
drugs somewhere when will that happen
you know we already are starting to see
the decriminalization in certain areas
of plant psychedelics
and we see overall drug drug crim like
that passed in oregon
so that any drug is now it's not legal
you can't
really fully set up clinics to
offer it to people or there's no legal
supply like that but
it's decriminalized so my sense of
things is based a lot on watching what
happened with medical marijuana and
marijuana legalization so we're sitting
here in massachusetts where marijuana is
legal
but what happened first was medical
marijuana so
what we see is that medicalization
by demonstrating that under certain
contexts the risks are
much less than the benefits and then
there are benefits
and then people hear stories about
people that gotten better
and then that changes their minds then
eventually that builds up to why are we
throwing people in jail just the culture
yeah yeah so
i think that what we're going to have
2023 is
mdma approved by the fda chances are
psilocybin will be a year or two after
that then what we're going to need is a
decade of psychedelic clinics
that are going to roll out across
america
also other countries as well thousands
of these psychedelic clinics
we already have hundreds of ketamine
clinics
that are academy for depression more and
more people are realizing that ketamine
when it's used with therapy it's better
than when it's not
but the therapists want to be
psychedelic therapists they don't want
to be a ketamine therapist or an mdma
therapist so those the cross-trained
so we'll have a decade of these
thousands of psychedelic clinics and all
these stories of people getting better
in 2035
is when i think that we will move to
licensed legalization
which is when you will have the option
of just going somewhere
once you've done this educational stuff
potentially
i also think it would be better to have
the opportunity for people to go
for free paid for by tax money to these
clinics and you have your first
experience with psychedelics under
supervision
and you know what you're getting into
you've you know
asked a questionnaire what the risks are
with the drugs then you get your license
so 2035 is when i think that'll happen
and the clinics will be sites of these
initiations
yes and so be a safe environment just
like you said all the things that are
actually
um maximize the likelihood of a pleasant
experience and all those kinds of things
it is a frustratingly slow process um
and the
fda being part of that process is very
frustrating that
of course there's there's benefits but
uh boy i wish you could move a lot
faster
yeah well one thing that i've learned
from being a parent
is that when you have little kids it
seems like they'll be with you forever
but then when they grow up and they go
to college and they leave you look back
and like where did that
20 years go you know so
we're still dealing with the legacy of
the civil war and slavery in america
yeah so actually a 20-year plan is not
that long
so while we say um
it's frustratingly slow and it is you
know i mean it's 50 years
since uh the psychedelic 60s and you
know
when right now it's um
you know it's 36 years since mdma was
criminalized and you think about all
those people that committed suicide from
ptsd or
from anything else and all those people
that could have been helped
if the dea had accepted the
administrative law judge recommendation
that mdma
stay in schedule three it's it's
tremendously sad
at the same time culture evolves slowly
you know you read the bible or you read
all the stuff we're not that different
from people thousands of years ago
so how are we going to really evolve
enough over the next couple decades so
we don't destroy the planet and don't
kill each other um
that's why i think psychedelics have an
important role to play
that's why i've devoted my life to
psychedelics and it is frustratingly
slow
and what i said to myself is our whole
effort has not been fast enough
you